hello everyone and welcome to another
incredibly exciting game from
yesterday's european team championship
it's aboard one of armenia versus france
and it's uh an incredibly incredible
game it's it's basically a perfect game
you'll see what i mean by this so let's
dive straight into it there's quite a
lot to cover so onboard one for armenia
gabriel sergician opens with d4
uh we have d5 by all it is c for e6
knight to f3 sorry not e6 c6 knight to
f3 and now knight to f6 uh we ignite the
c3 and now usually you just go for e6
and complete your setup for the for the
semi-slav but also d captures on c4 is
very very popular so here black is
preparing to
play b5 maybe defended the c4 pawn white
of course wants to play e3 and pick up
the pawn so to prevent the b5 we will
play a4
and now bishop to f5 y plays e3 prepares
to pick up the pawn on c4 and now e6 we
have bishop captures on c4 and bishop to
b4 now so this has all been played many
many times nothing new or out of the
ordinary here and black can be very
happy with his development both of the
bishops are out the 90s here
uh you know not lacking in development
in any way so here we have castles so
black also castles and the queen to e2
developing the queen uh when when this
once the bishop is developed the rooks
will be connected and also the queen
nicely defends the bishop on c4 which is
very useful in a lot of these lines so
here we have bishop back to g6 you don't
want to uh experience e4 with tempo
bishop moves and then e5 so
it could be a lot for black to handle so
just knight bishop back to g6 and knight
to e5 attacking the bishop and just
enjoying a very nice square for his
knight so knight b to d7 trying to trade
off uh the pair of knights and the
sergio now trades on g6 so knight
captures on g6 h captures and rook to d1
so very nicely played by both of them
this is all explored territory so
nothing uh you know new here queen to c7
developing the queen connecting rooks
and now e4 of course this e4 e5 idea um
is what white wants to play so black of
course prevents him alireza plays e5
himself
and now d5 and now there are many many
possibilities here and you can you know
pretty much any any move is um a good
move you can play knight
knight the b6 the pressure the bishop on
c4 you can play rook after d8 you could
play rook eight to c8 you could bring
this rook here you can bring this rook
here uh you could pretty much do
anything but here alireza just plays
bishop captures on c3 so just giving up
the uh not the bishop player but his
last bishop for this knight on c3 and it
is now as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game so what's uh what's
the plan here well he's uh asking white
uh whether he wants to capture on c3
right away or play uh d6 first because
while this bishop was on b4 uh the d6
square was guarded so you could never
push d6 so here the question is do you
want to capture and then allow c
captures on d5 which would reduce the
tension in the center or do you want to
keep the tension in the center and play
d6 first which of course creates some
complications and as alireza is uh
the first one to leave you know explore
the territory it's probably well within
his preparation but sergio accepts the
challenge and plays d6 he attacks
alireza's queen queen to a5 and now b
captures on c3 and you don't really gain
all that much by by grabbing the c3 pawn
basically you just help white to develop
uh so instead we have b5 attacking the
bishop on c4 and also the pawn on a4
because you can't capture a captures on
b5 the rook on a1 is undefended so again
you can see uh the the power or or
rather the lack off of not having your
rooks connected so here bishop back to
a2 and now b captures on a4 and for the
moment uh it's not a lot but alireza has
a past a pawn whereas white has a a past
d pawn so here we have bishop to a3 a
nice developing move you could also
consider uh some other moves for example
queen to d3 defends the c3 pawn but then
maybe knights the c5 attacks the queen
there's a double attack on the e4 pawn
so maybe not all that impressive so
instead we have bishop to a3 the bishop
fare here is now incredible and you're
asking black do you wanna do you wanna
capture on c3 and alireza goes for it he
just captures on c3 uh you could also uh
for example go knight to c through the
c5 right away put some pressure on this
pawn here but this is actually a trick
uh sergey sian prepared if knight to c5
queen to c4 now there's a double attack
on the knight here and if you capture
now uh this pawn here then d7 is
incredibly strong because the rook now
gets uh
you know exposed and also this bishop
queen battery is incredibly strong so
you can't move the rook
white would be much better here so all
it is it just captures the queen
on c3 with the queen
and now f3 uh solidifying the position
here the e4 pawn is now nicely defended
the bishops are excellently placed and
uh well you still have the the past the
deep one for the moment you can't push
it but it's a it's a very nice position
uh for white so all it is it starts
bringing the rooks into the game uh rook
a to b8 and now comes rook d to c1
chasing away the queen queen to d for
check and now king to h1
and now we have c5 so now
the bishop is no longer guarding the d6
pawn queen captures on d6 is the threat
so uh gabriel just plays rook to d1
attacks the queen and the d6 pawn will
now be nicely defended so queen to c3
and now rook d back to c1 again you have
to figure out how to defend your bishop
on a3 and probably bishop to c4 is the
safest way to do it now you just defend
it but sergey and decides to defend it
with a with a tactic rook ate this rook
d to c1 not saying that if you capture
the bishop then i will capture on f7
with check and then i'm gonna win your
queen so of course alireza doesn't do
that after this rook
d to c1 he just goes back to a5 and now
rook back to d1
uh this rogue belongs on d1 so that's
maybe why the whole bishop the c4 plan
uh was better than this uh sort of a
tricky rook the c1 to d1 maneuver but
okay alexa goes queen to b5 now offers a
queen trade and uh sargisian declines
queen to c4 and while doing so improves
the activity of his light square bishop
queen to c6 uh and now comes rook a to
c1 so how can alerza make some progress
here he he has two uh two pass pawns
white has only one uh and um well it's a
double a pawn but still it's uh
definitely something to look forward to
so rook to b6 this is uh alireza's plan
he wants to put more pressure on this
pawn here play the queen back to b8 and
then just pick up the the d6 pawn so
queen to f2 now the c5 pawn uh is being
pressured quite a lot here but also
there's the threat of queen to g3
followed by queen captures on g6 because
the f7 pawn is pinned uh or you know
that one might think there is but here
comes queen to c8 this is how all it is
that wants to bring the queen to the b8
square uh and now uh how do you go about
this well the simplest way is maybe just
rook to d3 followed by rook c to d1 uh
add another defender to to help out with
the defense of the d6 pawn but white
played queen to g3 and this is the
magic moment of the game uh you know
some would say even a critical moment
where queen captures and g6 is being
threatened and how do you how do you
defend against such a threat well there
are a couple of moves that you could
play but alireza finds the the uh
absolutely most brilliant one and that
i'm not even going to ask you to find it
because it's impossible to find this and
that is queen to b8 so what is so
incredible about this move uh well the
thing is if you capture on g6 now
alireza had rook to b3 planned so if you
guys uh you know were able to see this
so sorry for not asking you to pause the
video but it you know it just seems like
an incredible sequence of moves uh you
know a serious series of moves uh one
might say and what do you play now the
bishop here is attacked and there's
nothing you can do if you capture the
rook we're just gonna capture the bishop
here and now you're not pinning the f7
pawn anymore so the queen is hanging and
also the bishop on a3 is hanging so
that's out of the question the only
thing you could do after rook to b3 is
maybe play rook to a1 to defend this
bishop but not rook to c3 and again
there's no uh defense here uh you're
either losing this bishop or you move
the bishop and then we're gonna pick up
the queen because there's really no good
square for you uh to to move your bishop
if you play with bishop back to a2 to
keep uh control of the diagonal we can
just blow we can even capture on a3 but
we can also just block with c4 and now
the this is a threat also we can just
capture here on the next move so you
cannot play that uh so after this queen
to b8 move white finds himself uh in a
very tricky situation what do you play
here uh because white thought that queen
to g6 unless black somehow miraculously
defends this is impossible
so here uh white played bishop back to
a2 it's sort of a waiting move but also
uh
the c5 pawn is now uh under attack uh
and uh he's basically waiting for
alireza to capture on on v6 that way the
rook will no longer have access to the
b3 square so while it is a goes for this
rook captures on d6 and now we can
finally capture on g6 so queen captures
on g6 rook captures on d1 rook captures
on d1 and now queen to b5 this is the
the tricky move uh now queen to e2 is is
the threat this will attack the rook on
d1 and the bishop on a2 and also will
nicely support maybe the
advancement of the of the past c pawn so
you have to move the queen queen to g5
now comes queen to e2 attacking the rook
and the bishop and although you could
defend it with rook a1 this is i mean
too passive to even consider so of
course queen back to d2 now everything
is nicely protected and now alireza goes
for this end game queen captures rook
captures and now we have this incredible
end game where it's two knights against
the two bishops but also alireza is up
two pawns uh it's it's a doubled a pawn
but still two pawns are two pawns so how
but the bishop
on the other hand is is the bishop pair
so how do you continue here well i'll it
is of course starts by activating the
rook rook the c8 he wants to start
pushing his spawn and this is another
very interesting moment in the game
where uh white played king the g1 and
it's a move you always want to play you
want to start bringing your king into
the game and you know if you've if
you've ever read like a book on end
games you know king activity is number
one you know bring your king into the
game
uh activate your king that's how end
games are played but here there's one
move that maybe improves white's
position a bit too much for for it to be
ignored uh and that move is rook to c2
and as you'll see the end game can be
very unforgiving so here rook the c2
kind of prevents black from
making uh any uh sudden advancements
because now uh the pawn can't really be
pushed the c4 square is nicely protected
and also you can't really move this
knight to help out with the push of the
pawn because the c5 pawn is hanging so
rook the c2 is uh definitely an
improvement before starting uh to bring
your king into the game but king the g1
was played
and this allows alvarez just enough time
to get things going uh on the queen side
so c4
now this is possible because the rook is
no long
not yet on c2 so rook to c2 now but now
knight b6 defending the the pawn uh we
have king to f2 now comes knight after
d7 king to e3 and the knot knight to c5
this is played played to absolute
perfection by alireza and now
it seems like the the c4 pawn can be
captured but not really if you capture
on c4 just knight e6 and how do you play
this your your bishop is hanging here if
you play king to d3 to defend the knight
f4 check and now you have to move the
king you're going to lose the bishop
either away away from the bishop or in
front of the rook so the bishop will be
undefended or you could move the bishop
but even that it doesn't help if bishop
d3 to guard the rook we can simply trade
captures captures and now knight the c4
check picks up the
uh poor bishop on a3 so that's the
problem with grabbing the pawn so this
is impossible we have bishop back to b2
now putting pressure on the e5 pawn but
now knight to d3 defending the e5 pawn
and getting excellent activity for this
knight bishop to c3 getting the the
bishop out of harm's way and now even a3
so grabbing so much space here that it's
very very difficult for black to even
find the move so here we have bishop to
d2 opening up
a discovery
from the rook to the pawn here uh
putting some pressure to this spawn
but now comes rook to c5
and now uh this rook will be activated
via via the b file so we have king back
to e2 and now knight to f4 with check
going after the g2 pawn capturing the
knight doesn't really do all that much
because how are you ever making progress
here with white there's no way to
to do anything you can just wait for for
black to you know bring his king into
the game and that's pretty much it
so instead we have king to f1 guarding
the g2 pawn now rook to b5 and now why
is alireza again offering this pawn here
well if you capture it for example
bishop captures on c4 we can simply
capture it and after rook captures
there's the simple a2 and how are you
how are you stopping this pawn from from
winning the game if you go rook to c1 we
can simply play rook to b1 that's game
over and if you play something like
bishop to c3 again rook delivers check
and after king f2 just a one queen we
win the bishop and of course the game so
instead after rook to b5 bishop to c5 c1
was played right away we of course want
to prevent the rook from infiltrating
all the way to the b2 square
but now the game is completely lost and
there is one move that really shatters
all of white's hopes in this game so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for alireza well i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this end
game brilliancy and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course rook to b3 that's the good stuff
and here after this movie is played
there is no move white can make the
position is now completely unplayable
because white's only hope was to maybe
pick up this pawn and then you know
continue the game but now there are no
moves for white uh the thing is if you
let's say you capture on f4 first e
captures on f4 nothing is is really
happening here and if you really go
after the rook with the bishop captures
on b3c captures on b3 the two pass pawns
are too strong this captures also comes
with tempo the rook is attacked and once
the rook moves we just play b2 and
that's it you could play something like
captures captures and rook to b3 try and
play rook against two knights but knight
c4 defends our past pawn and now just
the other pass pawn starts marching
forward this is this is game over so
after this rook to b3 a rook captures on
c4 seems like the only option left so
this is what um
gabriel played uh but now comes knight
captures on c4 interestingly there was
an even a crazier line but the the the
one that alireza played is sufficient
but there is the rook to d3 move uh with
the white rook still being attacked and
rook to d1 being a threat now the thing
is after the rook moves the point is uh
rook to d1 check king f2 and now rook
captures on c1 this is what you have to
find uh point is now that after rook
captures knight to d3 check picks up the
rook so of course that's completely
winning uh so you're not going to play
that you're going to play something like
bishop captures on f7 king of fate and
rook captures on a7 but now rook to c2
with check king to f1 and now rook to c3
guarding this pawn you're up a piece and
you're of course completely winning
there's no compensation here for white
uh but okay already went uh uh you know
uh with the simpler idea as it's also
completely winning knight captures on c4
we have bishop captures on b3 and now
knight to d3 you have to find the knight
to d3 move in order to decide to go for
this it's knights against bishops but
the knights are
completely overpowered here
uh so here what do you play yeah if you
just trade uh then the position is
completely winning there's no defense
against pawn to a2 once king you one is
played you're going to play a2 and white
has to give up the bishop we are of
course completely winning in this end
game so bishop to g5 is played and but
now knight to a5 there is uh no no tempo
for white here to you know catch his
breath uh the bishop is attacked the
show back to 82 now knight to b4 again
uh attacks the bishop and if you move
the bishop a2 just wins the game so of
course that cannot be played bishop to
d2 is played and now ali is a happily
trades we have knight captures on a2
bishop captures on a5 and now knight to
c1 and again this cannot be prevented we
have bishop to c3 a2 and now finally
after bishop capture sunny 5 knight to
b3 so
there is nothing white could have done
to prevent the advancement of the of the
past pawn
uh king e2 and now a1 queen of course we
will eliminate the white's uh
uh remaining piece so bishop captures an
a1 nine captures on a1 king to d3 and
knight b3 and he was in this position on
move 55 that gabriel sergio resigned in
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here so incredible incredible game
both of them played incredibly well but
alvareza you know
played it just a little bit better and
you know it was enough for him to win
the game it was not enough to win the
match armenia still won the match uh two
and a half to one and a half in aleris
one on board one and uh maxim bashar
lagrave drew on board too uh but armenia
was better on boards three and four four
so yeah even though alareza
played brilliantly like this on board
one they still lost the match uh but uh
this uh means uh uh you know wonders for
uh alireza as he is now i'm sure you
guys already know but he is now let me
just enlarge this a little bit uh on the
lives live rating list he has overtook
fabiano corona as a world number three
in classical rating you can see that his
current rating is now 27.93
so he is uh uh some six point seven
points six point seven uh uh points away
from uh from breaching that 2800 barrier
for the first time uh which would
definitely make him the youngest uh
player ever to do so uh so next on his
uh next time his menu is dinglin uh he's
uh you know less than uh
six points away from that and then
there's only one left but that will
require some time so we'll see will
alireza continue this ascend will anyone
be able to stop him this uh i mean this
game just proves how how incredibly how
incredibly strong he is in in any
position
and this uh moment here where
uh let me just quickly rewind this uh
where
yeah where white went for this uh
uh attractive looking queen to g3 move
instead of going for the calm rook to d3
rook to d1 with just you know guarding
the the the d6 pawn uh just shows you
how how strong alireza can be and how
deadly in any position just finding a
move like queen to b8 i mean incredible
uh allowing this and you know
it fails to rook to b3 this is i mean
incredible stuff
so i'm very very very glad um uh you
know i showed this game hope you guys
enjoyed it as well we'll see uh how far
ali alireza can go and will he you know
encounter some obstacles before
breaching that 2800 barrier or will he
just you know blast through it
uh so once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank uh dylan
streeter benjamin echenlor branislav uh
frankfully and uh michael kennedy for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice event
checking up on what uh uh else is
happening in the chess world and of
course on your wonderful suggestions
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day